i never got to buy you that drink last
night they were free
i don't patrick j adams just gave a
master class on being a loyal friend
so i don't think megan needs any tips
about anything on friday the 39-year-old
actor who co-starred with meghan markle
on
suits for nearly a decade took to
twitter to slam the royal family and the
recent reports of bullying aimed at the
duchess of sussex
the times newspaper has reported that
the duchess allegedly
bullied two members of her household
staff out of kensington palace and made
the life of the third member of staff
almost unbearable um those are the
allegations they are strongly refuted
by the duchess of sussex who says she
didn't bully anyone
out of the palace adams didn't hold back
calling the palace's recent response to
the allegations of bullying against
markle quote
another stunning example of the
shamelessness of an institution that has
outlived its relevance
is way overdrawn on credibility and
apparently
bankrupt of decency adams also reminded
his followers that markle is
currently pregnant with her second child
adding that he thought the royals would
stop
sharpening the knives after the may 2019
birth of markle and prince harry's son
archie but instead the hunt continued
it sickened me to read the endless
racist slanderous click-baiting vitriol
spewed in her direction from all manner
of media across the uk
and the world but i also knew that megan
was stronger than people realized or
understood and they would regret
underestimating her
megan who is a spokesperson for women
around the world
who who claims in her own statement and
has spoken very publicly about
being the subject of bullying she's
talked about online bullying and
trolling and
being bullied in the media now having to
fend off claims
that she in fact has been a bully adams
went on to call the royal family dynamic
quote seemingly archaic and toxic
and praised his friend and former
co-star for how she's handled herself in
recent years
calling markle a powerful woman with a
deep sense of morality and a fierce work
ethic
quote she has never been afraid to speak
up be heard and defend herself and those
she holds dear
like the rest of the world i have
watched her navigate the last few years
in astonishment
he went on to shut down anyone attacking
her character
once again complimenting her character
as enthusiastic
kind cooperative giving joyful and
supportive
and then he took one last jab at the
royal family
quote find someone else to admonish
berate and torment
my friend megan is way out of your
league oh i have no idea
why they do what they do adam's tweets
come after the times published an
article claiming that markle
bullied her royal aides a spokesperson
for markle and prince harry has denied
the allegations in a statement to e.t
calling it a quote calculated smear
campaign based on misleading and harmful
information
following the allegations buckingham
palace announced they're launching
an internal investigation what is right
about this time well so many things
um that were on the other side
of a lot of a lot of the life experience
that's happened and also that we have
the ability to make our own choices in a
way that
i couldn't have said yes to you then of
course markle and prince harry's highly
anticipated interview with oprah winfrey
airs sunday on cbs
and in a sneak peek the 39 year old
opens up about how she feels about
having the palace
hear what she and prince harry have to
say i don't know
how they could expect that after all of
this time
we would still just be silent if there
is an active role
that the firm is playing in perpetuating
falsehoods about us and if that comes
with risk of losing things i mean i've
there's a lot that's been lost already